♪ ♪
>> Bret: THIS WEEK MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS EXPERIENCED A
THANKSGIVING LIKE NO OTHER WITH
HEIGHTENED RESTRICTIONS PUT IN
PLACE BY GOVERNORS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND RESPONSE TO SPIKES
IN CORONAVIRUS CASES.
JOINING ME NOW FROM LITTLE ROCK
IS ARKANSAS
GOVERNOR ASA HUTCHINSON, VICE
CHAIR OF THE NATIONAL GOVERNORS
ASSOCIATION.
GOVERNOR, WELCOME TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY"."
>> Governor Hutchinson:
THANK YOU, BRET, IT IS GOOD TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY.
>> Bret: ARKANSAS HAS BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS, AND WHERE DO
YOU THINK YOUR STATE IS JUST AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS AS OF LAST WEEK
FRIDAY?
IT SURPASSED 1,000 FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN YOUR STATE.
A TOUGH NUMBER.
WHERE ARE YOU?
>> WELL, THE HOSPITALIZATIONS IS
THE GREAT CONCERN AND THAT IS A
RECORD NUMBER OF COVID PATIENTS
THAT WE THOUGHT HOSPITALIZED.
IT HOPEFULLY WILL STABILIZE.
WE HAVE A HOSPITAL GROUP THAT’S
WORKING WITH ME VERY CLOSELY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE ADEQUATE HOSPITAL SPACE FOR
BOTH COVID PATIENTS, WHICH IS
REALLY A MINORITY OF THOSE THAT
ARE IN THE HOSPITAL, AS WELL AS
CARING FOR ALL THE OTHER
HEALTH CARE NEEDS THAT WE HAVE.
DURING THE LAST THREE WEEKS
SINCE WE’VE HAD THIS MOST RECENT
SPIKE, THE PEOPLE OF ARKANSAS
ARE TAKING THIS EXTRAORDINARILY
SERIOUSLY.
I THINK WE HAD A VERY SUBDUED
THANKSGIVING.
WE ARE VERY THANKFUL, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE
RISK OF LARGE GATHERINGS AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF SOCIAL DISTANCING.
WE ARE TRYING TO TAKE THE
APPROACH THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR GUIDELINES ARE
FOLLOWED.
WE’VE INCREASED OUR ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS.
WE’VE WORKED WITH OUR HOSPITALS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE SPACE
THERE.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO SHUT DOWN
BUSINESSES THAT ARE DOING A
GOOD JOB.
WE STILL HAVE SOME LIMITATIONS
AND SPACING IN OUR RESTAURANTS
AND GYMS.
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT TO BE
ENFORCED BUT WE REALIZE THAT YOU
COULD REALLY INCREASE PROBLEMS
ACROSS THE BOARD IF YOU START
SHUTTING DOWN BUSINESSES,
PUTTING PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED AS WE
GO INTO THE CHRISTMAS SEASON.
>> Bret: YOU MENTIONED
ENFORCEMENT, YOU HAVE A
STATEWIDE MASK MANDATE AND
YOU’VE HAD SOME DOCTORS WRITE
YOU A LETTER SAYING THEY WOULD
REALLY LIKE YOU TO ENFORCE THAT.
IT STATES THAT IT COULD RESULT
IN A $500 FINE.
ARE YOU DOING THAT ON A MASK
MANDATE FRONT?
>> Governor Hutchinson: WELL,
IN TERMS OF OUR RESTAURANTS, OUR
REGULATED INDUSTRIES, WE HAVE
INSPECTIONS, WE ARE ENFORCING
THE MASK MANDATE, THE SPACING
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL.
IN TERMS OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION, WE HAVE TO RELY UPON
OUR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THAT’S A GAP, BECAUSE THERE’S A
LOT OF HESITANCY ABOUT GOING OUT
AND ARRESTING SOMEONE FOR NOT
HAVING A MASK ON, AND SO THERE’S
A WARNING THAT’S GIVEN, WE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICIALS TO
INCREASE THAT EDUCATION PART OF
IT AND THE COMPLIANCE EFFORTS ON
THE MASK.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND WE HAVE THAT MASK
MANDATE IN ARKANSAS, VAST
MAJORITY ARE FOLLOWING THAT.
WE PUT IN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO AN AD CAMPAIGN STRESSING
THE SCIENCE BEHIND THE REASON WE
NEED TO DO THAT.
I THINK THAT’S THE RIGHT
APPROACH, WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR MORE WAYS TO STRENGTHEN THAT
COMPLIANCE AND MAKE IT BETTER.
>> Bret: ON THE FLIP SIDE, YOU
HAVE MADE CLEAR, AND YOU JUST
DID, THAT THERE WILL BE NO
SHUTDOWN OF BUSINESSES AGAIN.
>> Governor Hutchinson: WELL,
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU EVER SAY
NEVER, BUT THAT’S THE LAST THING
THAT WE WANT TO DO AND
PARTICULARLY SHUTTING DOWN A
BUSINESS THAT HAS WORKED HARD
FOR THE LAST EIGHT MONTHS TO
COMPLY WITH EVERY PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTIVE AND THEY HAVE A SAFE
POSITIONS WITHIN THEIR
RESTAURANT AND THEY HAVE NO
CASES COMING OUT OF IT.
AND SO THAT TO ME IS JUST
FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG TO SAY
YOU’RE OUT OF BUSINESS NOW AND
THAT YOUR WORKERS ARE
UNEMPLOYED, PARTICULARLY
WHENEVER THERE’S NOT ANY CARES
ACT RELIEF PACKAGE ANYMORE.
THAT MONEY HAS BEEN ALLOCATED.
WE’VE TRIED TO HELP OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES, BUT WE ARE NOT ABLE
TO COMPENSATE SOMEONE FOR THEIR
LOSS OF A JOB, FOR THEIR LOSS OF
AN INCOME AND SHUTTING DOWN THE
BUSINESS.
SO WE WANT TO BE SMART ABOUT IT
AND SO WE DID PUT AN 11:00 P.M.
CURFEW ON BARS AND RESTAURANTS
TRYING TO BREAK UP THE LATE
NIGHT CROWDS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE DON’T
WANT TO OVERLY RESTRICT OUR
BUSINESSES THAT ARE DOING A
GOOD JOB OUT THERE, BECAUSE THAT
JUST MAKE THE PROBLEM WORSE.
>> Bret: SHOULD ARKANSAS
STUDENTS BE BACK IN SCHOOL
PHYSICALLY AS OPPOSED TO
VIRTUALLY?
>> Governor Hutchinson: I’LL
TELL YOU A STORY, I JUST KNOW OF
A COUPLE THAT ARE BOTH WORKING
IN THE SCHOOL HAD TO GO VIRTUAL
AND SO WHAT YOU DO WITH THE
CHILDREN WHEN BOTH PARENTS ARE
WORKING?
THEY HAD THEM STAY OVER AT A
FRIEND’S HOUSE AND THE CHILD WAS
POSITIVE WITHIN DAYS BECAUSE OF
THE FRIEND.
AND SO THE IMPORTANT THING IS
THAT THE SCHOOL IS A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT.
WE HAVE THE OPTION TO GO VIRTUAL
AND TO PIVOT THERE BASED UPON
LOCAL DECISIONS AND LOCAL CASES,
BUT TO SAY CARTE BLANCHE WE ARE
GOING TO CLOSE OUR SCHOOLS, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE THE IN
CLASSROOM STRUCTURE AS AN OPTION
WOULD REALLY HAVE SOME ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE DON’T NEED
AND ARE NOT NECESSARY.
AND SO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP THOSE OPEN WITH THE OPTION
TO PIVOT TO VIRTUAL BASED UPON
LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES BUT WE WANT
TO MINIMIZE THAT EFFORT WHEN WE
CAN.
GOING TO SCHOOL IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
ON THE HIGHER EDUCATION SIDE,
YOU KNOW, AS OUR STUDENTS COME
BACK, WE WANT THEM TO GET
TESTED.
WE WANT THEM TO -- IF THEY’VE
BEEN IN A HOT ZONE OR THEY’VE
BEEN AMONG PEOPLE OR NOT
PROTECTED, TO MAKE SURE THEY
ISOLATE OR THEY GET TESTED AS
THEY COME BACK.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TURN FOR A
MINUTE TO THE ELECTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, GOVERNOR, AS
YOU KNOW HAS NOT CONCEDED THE
ELECTION.
HE CONTINUES TO SAY THAT IT WAS
STOLEN.
COMPUTER EXPERTS WITHIN HIS OWN
ADMINISTRATION HAVE PUSHED BACK
ON THAT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH FRAUD
THAT WE HAVE UNCOVERED AS A
CAMPAIGN AND LISTEN, PEOPLE NEED
TO KNOW GOING FORWARD, IT’S NOT
JUST ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT EVERY
ELECTION WE HOLD IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA IS FAIR
AND LEGAL AND EVERY LEGITIMATE
BOAT GETS COUNTED.
>> IT’S THE MOST SECURE IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT ANY
VOTING SYSTEM DELETED OR LOST
VOTES OR CHANGED VOTES OR WAS IN
ANY WAY COMPROMISED.
>> I STAND BY THAT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
100% CONFIDENCE IN THEIR VOTE.
>> Bret: SO GOVERNOR, HAVE YOU
SEEN ANYTHING THAT SUGGESTS THAT
THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT COULD PREVAIL IN
OVERTURNING THE ELECTION THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN CERTIFIED IN A
NUMBER OF KEY STATES?
>> Governor Hutchinson: MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE COURTS HAVE NOT
SEEN ANY EVIDENCE OF SUCH
EXTENSIVE FRAUD THAT THEY HAVE
TO CHANGE THE RESULT.
SCORES OF COURTS HAVE LOOKED AT
THAT AND SO THAT’S WHY THE
GENERAL SERVICE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZED VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
AS PRESIDENT-ELECT.
HE IS PRESIDENT-ELECT.
WE NEED TO WORK THAT TRANSITION.
I APPLAUD PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
INITIATING THAT TRANSITION AND
MAKING SURE THAT THAT IS
HAPPENING.
THE WORST THING THAT COULD
HAPPEN IS THAT WE DO NOT HAVE A
SMOOTH HANDOFF WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR VACCINE DISTRIBUTION, PLANS,
OUR WORK SPEED, AND THAT TAKES
THAT TRANSITION TO START NOW AND
I’M GRATEFUL THAT IT HAS.
BUT I DO THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE ELECTIONS, IT WOULD BE GOOD
AFTER THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
BIPARTISAN REVIEW AS TO WHAT’S
BEST PRACTICES, BECAUSE THIS IS
GOING TO COME UP AGAIN AS TO HOW
TO HANDLE ABSENTEE VOTES, WHAT’S
THE BEST WAY TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF THOSE VOTES TO GIVE
PEOPLE CONFIDENCE.
AND THAT’S NOT TO SAY EVERYTHING
WAS FRAUDULENT IN THIS ELECTION,
IT JUST SAYS THAT WE NEED TO
LEARN FROM EACH OTHER, ALL THE
50 STATES, AND WHAT WE HAVE DONE
AND HOW WE CAN DO IT BETTER AND
TO GIVE PEOPLE CONFIDENCE THAT
IS SO IMPORTANT IN OUR DEMOCRACY
DEMOCRACY.
>> Bret: SEE YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD OFFICIALLY
CONCEDE?
>> Governor Hutchinson:
WELL -- I UNDERSTAND THE LEGAL
REASON WHY HE SHOULD NOT BECAUSE
HE HAS APPEALS GOING, SO I
RECOGNIZE THAT BUT BEYOND THAT,
IT’S PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
TRANSITION.
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE.
WE EXPECT THEM TO BE SWORN IN IN
JANUARY EVEN THOUGH THERE’S
GOING TO BE SOME CONTINUED
REVIEWS, WHICH I RESPECT.
AND IT’S NOT THAT IMPORTANT --
THE TRANSITION IS WHAT IS
IMPORTANT.
THE WORDS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP ARE
NOT QUITE AS SIGNIFICANT, BUT
THE ACTIONS ARE IMPORTANT IN
HELPING IN THIS TRANSITION TO
MAKE SURE THAT PRESIDENT-ELECT
BIDEN IS READY TO GO ON JANUARY